[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock it seems to be a tale of two
festive seasons
england's chief medical officer wants us
to scale back our christmas plans boris
johnson says he is not cancelling
parties or bringing in further
restrictions that's despite a record
number of covey cases and a warning of
worse to come
meantime there are more calls for more
government support for the hospitality
industry as bookings are cancelled we'll
speak to the health minister julian
keegan very shortly also ahead
sign here please prime minister we'll
hear from the men selling the autographs
of 55 british prime ministers from the
last 300 years
[Music]
is that the christmas number one the
cafe owner challenging the pop stars for
the crown to raise money for
dementia research chatting to him it's
thursday the 16th of december
curb your enthusiasm england's chief
medical officer urges people to cut back
on socializing but the pm seems less
cautious as the threat from omicron
increases
there's almost no scenario in which the
nhs will not be overwhelmed and given
that we know that
it's quite astonishing that we're not
taking early action
crisis at christmas the hospitality
industry calls on the government to dish
out more financial help as it faces a
wave of festive cancellations
up the rollouts there's no let up in the
push to get as many people as possible
vaccinated with the kovid booster jab
i'll have the latest from here in
blackburn
not in touch new figures reveal hundreds
of thousands of people with covid19
aren't using nhs track and trace to
alert their close contacts
two people are still missing after a
suspected arson attack at a block of
flats in reading
on the ground president biden travels to
kentucky to see the tornado
[Music]
devastation morning everybody should we
party on down or should we hunker down
it seems is up to you in the run-up to
december the 25th boris johnson insists
christmas gatherings aren't cancelled
and there won't be any more restrictions
but england's chief medical officer
wants us to think carefully about who we
choose to socialize with as the omicron
variant spreads with record-covered
cases the hospitality sector says it
needs more government cash as
cancellations rise here's ivy bennett
at the turn stars last night it was a
case of tickets please and covet passes
football fans among those who now have
to show proof of double vaccination or a
negative test at large events in england
enthusiasm for the match appeared
unaffected but there was cause for
concern when it came to christmas
we're just gonna lay low um in the
run-up after this yeah
so no socialising from now until the big
day yeah probably not yeah this is the
last one a lot smaller this year than
normal a lot smaller is that as a result
of the recent rising cases oh absolutely
yeah no plans to cancel unless the
advice changes
the advice may not have changed but the
language certainly has england's chief
medical officer saying people should
think twice about socializing in light
of the highest number of daily coveted
cases so far a record he warned that
will continue to be broken i'm afraid we
have to be realistic that records will
be broken a lot over the next few weeks
as the rates continue to go up i do
think people should prioritize what
matters and that by definition means
de-prioritize other things and i think
people are doing that and i think i
would recommend that
but the comments have been criticized by
a hospitality sector that's becoming
more restive than festive over concerns
customers will stay away
many bars and restaurants are struggling
to cope as it is with the surgeon cases
causing staff shortages but now they
fear they'll also be hit by plummeting
consumer confidence and so the british
chamber of commerce is calling for new
financial support
there are calls too for new restrictions
amid warnings the rapid expansion of the
booster program is not rapid enough
compared to the spread of omicron
there's almost no scenario in which the
nhs will not be overwhelmed and given
that we know that
it's quite astonishing that we're not
taking early actions i mean certainly
boosters are being rolled out at pace
but anyone who's boosted today it'll
take two weeks for the booster to fully
act and
that seven doubling times from a base of
80 000.
for now though boosters are still the
main defense wembley stadium among a
number of new mass vaccination centers
prompting another piece of advice
if you're going to go to a stadium at
the weekend make it one where you can
get your vaccine
or help out to give a vaccine rather
than you know going to going to watch a
match
the scientists are clear people now have
to decide whether or not to change plans
for christmas iva bennett sky news
let's bring in the health minister
should we jillian keegan ms keegan
always great to see thanks for joining
us on the programme this morning chris
whittie's saying the uh overwhelming the
nhs is a serious threat that's his
prediction um we always ask ministers
about this time can you just tell us at
this stage how many people are in
hospital this morning with omicron
um there's a 774
in hospital oh sorry that's uh that's
total hospital yeah hospitalizations in
the last seven days with omicron there's
10 cases um with omicron
maybe going up to 11 actually that
wasn't confirmed yet but i think
probably gone up to 11.
how many deaths
uh the deaths um were a hundred and
oh i don't i don't i don't have that
from omicron
oh sorry sorry k
uh no we don't have um we've have one
death uh with omicron so far
how many of those 10 people with omicron
are on ventilators
i don't think there's anybody that i'm
aware of on a ventilator with omicron
okay uh professor whitty's saying people
should be so what you're getting at is
the severity of the
you're getting at the severity of the
disease which is one of the other 10
people in hospital one of them died the
other 10 are not on ventilators that's
those are facts
professor whitley said people should be
prioritizing those things that really
matter to them this christmas don't mix
with people you don't have to
the prime minister then said we're not
cancelling people's parties or their
ability to mix
only one of them can be correct which
one is it
well actually if you listen to what the
premise has said in his entirety he was
also urging caution he was saying take a
test before you go out um you know if
you're meeting people check who it is
how many people you don't know check the
places well ventilated everybody's
urging caution it's highly transmissible
so everybody is urging caution and you
know before i go out to any event i'm
definitely going to take a test uh in
fact i took one today hoping to see you
in person k but uh you know that that
people will be uh cautious of course
because we know i mean most of us will
know somebody now who's uh who's got
who's positive with covid and that means
if you you know you if you've tested
positive uh then you'll be in isolation
over christmas so that's bound to make
people a bit more cautious
don't mix with people you don't have to
we're not cancelling people's parties or
their ability to mix
which one is it
well make a sensible choice for yourself
make a sensible choice you know if
you're going to go to a party take a
test if there's lots of people there you
don't know if that's your priority fine
if your priority is to make it through
to christmas day with your family then
take a different approach everybody's
got different pros and cons you know so
make a sensible decision but definitely
wear a mask
and definitely
you know
make sure that you take a test
beforehand and also try to go to
well-ventilated places as well
many uh i i've got one party which is
moved to to outside so uh hopefully
they've got some uh some some fire or
something outside or something just
forget to take your big coat with you
um
even if you're northern you still need
your big coat this weather um can you
rule out more restrictions between now
and christmas day
we're not intending to make any more
restrictions you know obviously we had
the debate uh this week it was a very
full debate and you know obviously we've
uh we've made a you know we voted on
that and we we have um you know we have
introduced those but of course the prime
minister said you know if we need to to
act he won't hesitate to act and if that
means recalling parliament then then
that's what we have to do you know all
of us um are you know going to be
continue to work continue to be
available uh to make sure we get
everyone boosted i mean that's why we're
trying to go so fast with the booster
program as soon as we can get everybody
boosted it takes a couple of weeks for
that wall of defense we'll go back up to
where we were so hopefully yes it's hard
right now but hopefully we'll be
through the other side of this quite
quickly as we boost most of the adult
population can you guarantee that
everybody who wants to boost a vaccine
will get one by new year's eve
yeah everyone who's eligible that's the
target i know it's a tough target it is
a very stretching target it will mean us
doing more per day than we've ever done
but that is what we're mobilizing for
we've got many more volunteers come
forward we've got many more hubs that
we're opening we're opening for longer
hours you've heard about some stadiums
that are going to be open over the
weekend everybody's rushing forward for
it so thank you so much to the british
people and thanks obviously to everybody
involved in the programme but it it you
know this is this is this is what we're
going to do we're going to it's a very
very ambitious target but we're going to
throw everything at it and we're all
going to be you know putting our hands
uh to the to the wheel to make sure we
get there are you confident that you
will get there
yes i think um the one thing i'm
confident about um and you know
obviously i'm a health minister now for
the last couple of months is you know
they they they can meet big targets the
the the infrastructure's there the
logistics are there obviously the army's
coming in to help masters of volunteers
are coming in to help um you know the
gps are obviously uh at the front line
uh you know 25 24 plus a million of us
have already been jabbed including me
i'm two weeks today so i'm hoping my
antibodies are quite high
yeah a daily telegraph reporting today
that the public have begun a
self-imposed
lockdown locked down by stealth is how
some are describing it businesses are
crying out for support we'll be speaking
to com tom carriage later he's hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of
cancellations in his restaurants what
support are you going to offer
businesses
well we do still have support in place
uh for businesses so we've still got v80
reductions we've still got business rate
cuts of 66 and we've still got recovery
loans in place and as i say we're hoping
this is quite a short period of time so
that we can you know get everybody
boosted and get that wall of defense
back up that's what we're trying to do
here um so hopefully you know we've got
those in place till march or may in some
cases but of course the chancellor keeps
everything under review
okay how concerned are you about more
restrictions or even closures needed for
schools going into january
well again we've um you know that's why
we've introduced the second uh dose of
vaccination for 12 to 15 year olds so
we're hoping all those that haven't been
vaccinated with their first dose come
forward um and those are eligible for
their second dose get those over the
summer holiday over the christmas
holiday period teachers get your
boosters um that is going to be the best
way that we're going to make sure that
we can
keep everything going really whether
it's schools or restaurants or
hospitality or you know many many things
will be requiring people to be there so
they're the best that's the best
approach come forward get your booster
or get your jab if you haven't had it
but hopefully that additional dose for
12 to 15 year olds will make a big
difference to their wall of defense so
you're confident that if the kids have
their jabs the 12 to 15 year olds that
all schools will open as they should do
for the start of the new term yes
yeah we i mean you know we saw how
devastating actually how devastating it
is uh on the impact on not only
education but mental health and uh all
kinds of things uh you know and when the
kids went back to school they were so
excited so no it's fully the intention
uh to uh keep schools open and obviously
that's why we've introduced these uh you
know new precautions and also uh an
extra dose of the vaccine
okay and uh before we let you go
talking to my team this morning um and
other colleagues and friends everybody
is so
weary they think they're thinking not
another christmas like last christmas
what's your message to a weary nation
thank you so much for everything you've
done for coming forward for getting the
booster for taking precautions for
acting sensibly for helping your
neighbors for helping your community for
volunteering thank you so much
have a peaceful christmas thank you for
taking the time and uh look forward to
seeing you in person in the new year
thank you
and happy christmas to everybody
thank you
and uh those christmas warnings that
we're hearing about dominating this
morning's front pages including the
telegraph which leads with scale back
christmas plans as professor whissey
urges the public to prioritize their
social interactions
similar headline on the times which also
picks up on the chief medical officer's
plea to cut back on socializing likewise
don't mix with friends unless you have
to is the headline in the eye
that warning is also echoed in the
guardian and the male has a slightly
different take on last night's news
conference saying it's boris versus the
scientists that's what i was putting to
the health minister a moment or two ago
a reminder that later this morning the
chief medical officer for england
professor chris whitty will give
evidence to the health and social care
committee on the latest findings about
the new omicron variant we'll have full
coverage on sky news from 10 30.
and if you want to take part or you want
to volunteer to take part in the covid
booster rollout then scan a qr code have
we got it
we'll show it to you in just a moment or
two put that qr code on the screen and
if you use that then it will show you
where you can volunteer to take part in
the covid vaccine rollout and i took
part in earlier in the year trust me
it's very very rewarding so do you bit
if you can still to come on the program
professor tim spectre the man behind the
zoe kovitt tracker app gives us his take
on omicron
and how it's spreading
chef and restaurateur tom carriage tells
us why he fears the hospitality industry
could crumble this winter and why
ministers need to act now
and we'll get labour's take on
challenges facing the nhs as omicron
spreads for the shadow health secretary
west streeting after eight o'clock
this morning vaccine centers across the
country are again attempting to deliver
a record number of booster shots to stop
the spread of omicron uh joining us now
is fraser he's in blackburn for us this
morning hello fraser um
not many people there yet but i'm
guessing they're planning for another
busy day
good morning kay yes they are certainly
hoping for a busy day and boris johnson
will certainly be hoping that centers
like this have a busy day the one here
in blackburn this pop-up center at the
hospital can accommodate around 750
people it's got the facilities to to get
750 people through in a day they're not
sure whether they're going to get that
money done today they've got about 50
bookings they say but they're also
open to walk-ins not all of the
vaccination centers are open to walk-ins
this one is so they're hoping that
they'll certainly be getting a good few
hundred people through the doors today
as they try and get on top of this wave
of the new omicron strain of the virus
professor witte was warning us last
night that we're facing uh the virus on
two fronts now that we have the existing
delta virus which has uh plateaued and
and seemingly leveled off in the numbers
of new cases but then of course we've
got the rising spike in the omicron
variant 78 000 new cases announced
yesterday the numbers are rising and
rising and professor witte was warning
that we are going to see more records
being broken in terms of the numbers of
people being infected what we won't want
to see a quarter record has been broken
in the number of hospitalizations and
deaths as a result of this but as it
stands at the moment the experts seem to
think that the omicron is a less vicious
a less uh serious strain of the of the
coronavirus itself but uh that doesn't
mean to say that people don't want to
catch it people are obviously trying to
take advice to uh to continue their
social distancing and to limit their
social activities and so on uh with the
government's advice but the main advice
is to get booked in for that booster jab
if you can it's opened up to 18 to 30
year olds so all over 18s can now book
their boosted jabs it is busy on the
website and you are one to try and
persevere that if you can't get a
booking through with the waiting system
to persevere try again later today maybe
even tomorrow okay fred thank you thanks
a lot
anecdotally uh lots of uh family and
friends have managed to book their
appointments over the next couple of
days so keep trying i also managed to
book some lateral flow tests online as
well yesterday so the system is catching
up don't um give up heart because you
want to have that family with your uh
family christmas with your loved ones
now taking a look at the latest daily
coronavirus figures for the uk seventy
eight thousand six hundred and ten new
cases of covert 19 recorded in the last
24 hours
as we reported earlier that's a record
number for a single day since the start
of the pandemic another 165 deaths have
been reported within 28 days of a
positive test hearing from the minister
one of those confirmed to be as a result
of omicron that brings the total number
of deaths in the uk to 146
7791
to the vaccine roll up 34 000 have
received their first dose of the vaccine
where have you been guys and uh 37
888 have had their second dose that
means the total number of people to have
received their second dose is more than
46
million
uh let's have a look at the boosters
656 000 yesterday receiving their
booster or third vaccine in the last 24
hours bringing the total to almost
pushing 25 million
also making the news this morning for
you the search is continuing for two
people missing after a suspected arson
attack in a block of flats in reading
one person died and thames valley police
say they do not expect any further
survivors a 31 year old man has been
arrested on suspicion of arson and
murder
four children have died and five
seriously injured following an accident
on a bouncy castle emergency services
were called after the inflatable lifted
into the air at a primary school in the
town of devonport it's thought high
winds raised it 10 meters from the
ground
government inspectors say migrants are
being held in very poor conditions after
arriving in kent despite home office
assurances
the inspectorate of prison says women
who reported being raped by smugglers
were not adequately supported and saying
it has a significant safeguarding
concern over unaccompanied children
president biden has visited kentucky to
see the devastation left by the tornado
there it ripped through the town of
mayfield
88 people killed when more than 30
tornadoes hit last week leaving
thousands homeless and without power
now most parents are unaware of the risk
of their children being exploited by
so-called county lines drug gangs
according to campaigners the children's
society is warning dealers will target
vulnerable youngsters during the
christmas holiday as lisa dyer reports
all of a sudden tina's 14 year old son
just changed
he would come home not talk to me be in
his bedroom more
and i would find like things in his room
like necklaces with bad boy signs rings
bandanas and i thought what's going on
here
he'd fallen in with an older gang who
were involved in robberies and drugs
they grew young boys because they're
vulnerable
by showing off with their cars their
flats apartments even girlfriends girls
showing them
sort of like employing them
you know one day you can have this if
you work for us
she thinks he's lucky to be alive after
they set a dog on him
either they were trying to kill him or i
think they were trying to frighten him
he probably just didn't do what they
wanted him to do and they must have said
well if you don't do this we'll put a
dog on to you
a charity thinks he was targeted by
county lines dealers who get youngsters
to ferry drugs from cities to rural
areas the new study found that four out
of five parents and carers are worried
about children being exploited to sell
drugs and the same proportion are
concerned that young people are being
groomed online by criminals
it is a growing problem made worse by
the pandemic and the time of year we've
got some real concerns that the moment
where we might be facing new lockdown
restrictions
that children may face school closures
and learning from previous lockdowns we
know that when children are not
accessing education they're often at
more risk from perpetrators looking to
control and exploit them
tina thinks her son has left the gang
but she can't be sure
what she does know is that he is scarred
both physically and mentally
lisa dowd sky news
more on that throughout the course of
the day here on sky news and don't
forget of course we will also be
bringing you chris witte he's going to
be updating us on the omicron variant at
10 30 live here on sky news neither the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
of the week will be rather cloudy but
mainly dry temperatures returning to
near average
mostly mild and cloudy with drizzle in
the south and a little rain in the
northwest central parts are clearer with
frost and fog in places
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
now
guess who is back and still wondering
wherever they flipping feel like it oh
yeah here they are for the last year
we've been following a herd of elephant
who packed up their trunks from a nature
reserve and went for a wander i can tell
you that they
have now reached yunnan province reports
say they have been pinching sugar canes
apparently local police say they all
suspect one elephant
has stolen
a traffic cone hello mate
you're having a little wander through
there he is with his it looks i mean i
think guilty as charged did you see that
there you go wandering off with his
maybe he thinks he's he can um maybe he
thinks it's a tree branch i don't know
is he going to take another one
no
some striking stories in today's papers
and we start with an image of some that
you may find distressing so look away
now if you but you know this is the way
it is uh from the mirror shows the
devastating effect that climate change
has had and also drought on the people
and animals of kenya breaks my heart six
giraffes which are reported to have died
after they got stuck in the mod trying
to find
a reservoir
now who does a whale a world famous
sports star call when he's going to
receive a knighthood there he is who
else but his mum of course the times has
this picture of lewis hamilton at
windsor castle receiving the honor from
the prince of wales yesterday
no doubt very very very proud mum next
to him carmen
apparently the english french rivalry
goes very deep this morning the times
has these pictures
from a recent meeting between the royal
navy
and the french counterpart as well as
military exercises apparently there is
intense competition between the two
nations
in chess
and just to show how seriously the crew
of hms dragon take things they have a
union flag covering the table as they
hosted the match not really sure who won
that and before i read the story i was
sure that was prince william
it's not though is that
could it be
i don't think it is finally we all have
our favorites when it comes to
supermarkets
and toffee here is uh no
exception there he goes he's in the mail
he is as you can see a hamster and he
turns his nose up at any cheese
unless it's from waitrose
i love it every little helps no i will
that's i know that's from another one um
so we'll have a look at more stories
from inside the newspapers for you later
on in the programme we'll also ask
professor tim spector the man behind the
zoe kovitt trucker app for his take on
the danger posed by omicron
[Music]
hello again everybody make a sensible
choice that's the message from the
government this morning on whether
people should socialize before christmas
england's chief medical officer says we
should think carefully about who we
choose to meet up with the health
minister julian keegan says further
restrictions are not needed if people
take additional precautions
make a sensible choice for yourself make
a sensible choice you know if you're
going to go to a party take a test if
there's lots of people there you don't
know if that's your priority fine if
your priority is to make it through to
christmas day with your family then take
a different approach everybody's got
different um pros and cons you know so
make a sensible decision but definitely
wear a mask
and definitely um you know
make sure that you take a test
beforehand
tomorrow's standing by for us tomorrow
good morning um
i'm a little bit confused about the
message still the politicians are
telling us party on and the scientists
are selling saying hunkadine
well i think the message even from the
ministers has changed subtly in the last
couple of days kay
up to now we've had so many cabinet
ministers on the program saying don't
cancel your christmas plans go out as
normal everything's going to be fine and
yet yesterday at that press conference
yes boris johnson did leave it to chris
whittie the chief medical officer to
deliver the really gloomy message which
is that cases of omicron are increasing
at a staggering rate doubling every
couple of days and that therefore it may
be worth limiting your social contact in
the run-up to christmas and we heard
pretty much the same message there from
the health minister julian keegan if
your priority is to spend christmas day
with your family maybe don't go to that
party at which there'll be lots of
people that you don't know and one of
them may give you covid and you may end
up in isolation so the government's
message now is to be cautious not just
to take a test which is what they've
been telling us thus far and to wear our
masks and all the places you need to
wear them but also perhaps to make a
conscious decision not to go to some
events because of the high risk of
getting covered so that is a shift what
jillian keegan also alluded to was of
course the knock-on effect all this
caution is having on the hospitality
industry because people are already
cancelling bookings deciding not to go
out because of that risk
she said at the moment the government is
not offering up any additional financial
support she said there is some still
there in terms of tax rate cuts but the
government isn't offering any more but
the chancellor would keep that under
review and i think we're already seeing
the pressure building for that as the
hospitality industry say look people are
already deciding to stay at home because
of the very real risk of catching covid
in the run-up to christmas and i think
that along with the pressure for more
restrictions is just going to get louder
in the coming days sure and um just a
quick thought on the fact that good if
confusing news when it comes to the
number of omicron cases in hospital
well she said that there are still 10
potentially 11 which has been the case
all of this week i think the point that
chris witty the chief medical officer
was making yesterday is that in terms of
the transmission it really is
unprecedented so we had 78 000 odd cases
yesterday we don't know how many of them
are omicron but it went up by nearly 20
000 yesterday if it's doubling every
couple of days we're quite quickly
getting into the hundreds of thousands
every day so even if it turns out that
it's not quite as severe which can't be
guaranteed and even if the vaccines the
boosters are pretty effective against it
you're still if you're looking at that
many cases we are going to see that
translate into hospitalizations and
deaths and in the next few weeks chris
whittie said that was pretty much nailed
on the scale of it we don't know but he
was suggesting we need to prepare for
the worst okay tomorrow thank you
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock of
course figures out today suggest
hundreds of thousands of people as we're
hearing from tomorrow with kovid19
aren't using nh track and trace to alert
their close contacts
let's get more on this now from our
technology journalist jeff white hello
to you jeff
good morning to you talk to us
about the fact that people are not is it
because they've not got that track and
trace on their app
well it's worth noting first of all this
is this is a different app to the one
that shows your vaccination status there
are two apps here and this is the
contact tracing app and
people have downloaded this app the idea
is if you get a positive pcr test you
can then use the app you can hit a
little button that says please let my
close contact know that i've tested
positive and they can then take the
appropriate action
and obviously as you'll remember this
resulted in the so-called pandemic that
happened over summer when as many as a
hundred thousand of these alerts were
being sent out every day but it is a key
weapon in fighting the spread of
chronovirus the question is how many
people are still using this contact
tracing app to alert their contacts to a
positive test and the figures i've been
looking at indicates probably not enough
in england and wales for example only
about half about 50 percent of people
who've downloaded the app are using it
to alert their close contact
and north of the border in scotland
things are even worse it's only about
one in five about 20 of people who've
downloaded the app are using it to alert
their close contacts and that's really
important because as you'll well know in
scotland what they've decided is if you
are close to somebody who's tested
positive for coronavirus you yourself
must isolate until you've passed a pcr
test well the question is how do you
know you've been close to somebody's got
covered one of the answers to that a key
answer is through the app there are
other ways of finding out if you've been
close to somebody who's tested positive
so there's the nhs test and trace system
but that's quite labor-intensive
the idea of the app is less
labor-intensive more widespread way of
getting the word out and according to
these figures not enough people are
using the app in the way that it was
intended and that's obviously going to
have a knock-on effect in terms of
isolation
okay thanks very much thanks a lot
now after a record number of daily
infections from omicron the chief
medical officer for england professor
chris witte says sadly we should expect
to see more records being set with the
spread of omicron
join now by the scientist who's
developed an app to help us learn more
about covid symptoms that's professor
tim spector hello to professor thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning what are the symptoms of omicron
well on the zodiac we've been tracking
symptoms uh since the very start of the
pandemic last march
and so
the only real early warning
device that's out there
and millions of people are still
reporting every day their symptoms so
what we've been able to do is to
see how they've changed over the last
month in
places like london where we know that
omicron has now replaced delta as the
main
variant that people are getting
and what broadly what we're seeing now
is
the majority of people testing pcr
positive actually have cold-like
symptoms
and they do not have
the classical um
triad of the old coveted symptoms of
fever loss of smell and taste and a
persistent cough so
it's it's slowly merged into into a a
more
uh
symptomatic milder condition that looks
just like a severe cold to many people
and i think this is what really needs
people need to know about um at this at
this time of year is don't wait for a
temperature loss of smell or cough
uh more than 50 percent of people in
london are presenting and never get
those other symptoms and yet they're
they testing positive so it's not
looking very different to what we were
seeing with delta
but i don't think most the public
realized that delta had already changed
into a very
cold-like
disease anyway for vaccinated people
which is mainly what the people we're
looking at
yeah that's certainly what my symptoms
were when it came to the delta variant
do you also track what happens during
the life of um that that covert
infection for somebody
yes we do so
if you go on the app uh you'll be asked
to log every day
and whether you have symptoms or not and
what those symptoms are
and
this allows us to say how long those
symptoms are lasting
and whether they uh
how they're comparing to delta or not
now we already knew that the delta
symptoms were milder than the the
previous variants
and it wasn't lasting as long we know
that in vaccinated people the average
duration of symptoms is is shorter
we don't yet have accurate data on
omicron because we've only really looked
at about a thousand or so cases
but so far
we're seeing fairly
short
time spans we're seeing fairly
mild illness nearly everyone has got
better by about five days but the caveat
is you know a lot of these people
who are getting infection in london now
are on the younger side
and um
we haven't got a lot of
very sick people that may be the ones
that who end up going to hospital but
generally for the average person who's
been
vaccinated or triple vaccinated
yes we are seeing quite a few infections
in those people but
so far the infections are
looking mild but they will include the
headache the fatigue the sore throat the
runny nose uh sneezing uh as as
as the
and quite bad fatigue as the top
symptoms
just before i let you go um papers this
morning saying a million people
isolating by christmas is that your
projection
well
it could well be but people might be
self-isolating just in case but i think
the lesson is um you know we do
i think there's projections where if
people did nothing
and uh i don't think it's quite as
gloomy as some of the predictions are
because people are sensible when they
see these reports
they're not going to want to go to some
big party they're not going to want to
mix with people who they don't know if
they've got cold symptoms or not and i
think people again and they're already
starting to behave like that from our
data in london so
i think it's going to be bad but perhaps
not as bad as
everyone is projecting
and the other thing i need to point out
is that i don't think that test and
trace is going to work in this scenario
because
it only takes about two days from
meeting someone to getting an infection
and that often isn't enough time
to do much about it you've already
spread it really by the time you be
contacted by uh test and trace in my
opinion so i think people need to do
their own
health check see if they got any cold
like symptoms meeting people get a a
lateral flow test just before you meet
them and make sure everyone else is
doing the same that's the that's the
safest way if you if you are going to go
out at this time of year
okay professor uh interesting stuff
thank you very much indeed for taking
the time thank you
now the prime minister warned medical
staff and pharmacists might have to work
throughout christmas as part of what he
called a great national fight back
against omicron let's get more on this
uh from the former head of the civil
contingencies secretariat mike grant
hello to you mike thanks for joining us
um goodness me what a challenge there is
ahead
we heard from the minister everybody who
wants one will get a covered vaccine um
booster by the 31st of december how
difficult will that be
very difficult
um it's obviously going to be very
difficult i mean the fact is we're not
very far away from the end of december
we're not very far away from christmas
when people want a bit of a rest
uh and there are big logistical
exercises to carry out to get it done in
my own area i know that the local
stature resilience forum the statutory
meeting of emergency planners across the
county where i am which is kent
have already put out
a um
a plea for help to help move vaccines to
gp surgeries from uh from hospitals for
example they're looking for more
volunteers as well who can come in and
stick stick needles into arms so it's
going to be a it's going to have to be a
big effort the effort also has to be
backed up by somebody giving clear
advice any clear advice we've seen so
far i think personally is from chris
whittake you don't have to do something
don't do it
because that will help and we've seen
that the the efforts you've made in your
package of the last two or three people
on the screen
how complicated this is and what people
need to know so i don't think they're
going to make it i think they'll try
very hard i think everybody out there
will try very hard and i think the
government has been a little remiss in
not saying to people it might not happen
but we're doing our very best to make it
happen
and they're not doing a lot to make sure
that their messages are consistent which
is a very serious error um
former head of civil contingency
secretariat back in uh
2001 was that the fuel crisis i'm
guessing when we couldn't get fuel with
the petrol that was the fuel crisis then
it was foot and mouth foot and mouth my
goodness
yeah those two those two things
basically spurred the setting up the
civil contingency secretariat as it is
today and then the civil contingencies
act of 2004. so those things told us
we're in in complicated circumstances
you need good coordination you need very
clear consistent messaging
everybody had pulled in the same
direction didn't put in the same
direction we don't quite know what the
direction is going to be
it was leading me to my question about
how much the public will put up with
i think the public will put up with
anything frankly if they're given clear
advice and clear reasoning i think the
problem we have with the press
conference
the prime minister gave the last one was
you had three people in front of us in
front of the cameras he said
quite different things the prime
minister said we're going to have a huge
natural effort we've got to get on with
it and we're going to get through this
the chief medical officer was
commendably clear it's dead simple if
you don't need to do something don't do
it
because it's not going to be very easy
to get through the next few weeks it's
going to be a pretty startling perhaps
slightly frightening exercise and we had
the head of primary care for the
nhs in england saying we need volunteers
now bluntly that goal could have been
done by one person in a short sharp
statement that would have got it across
um
we've just seen how much care you've
taken over giving people good advice on
what might be happening and what they
might do about it that needs boiling
down properly and repeating again and
again then people will put up with it
they put up all sorts of things in
wartime in peace time with the pandemic
what they will not put up with is
confusion
what are you going to do for christmas
uh well we have plans to see our family
everybody's going to get a little flow
test before they come and see us because
i was isolating for a large part of last
year and everybody's been triple jabbed
but if people don't feel safe they won't
come and we'll do it this way
and would you go to a party
no
that's the end of that then isn't it
i can see where that's what yeah what
about going to a restaurant or out for
dinner would you do that uh if the
restaurant was one we knew where the
precautions were safe where the windows
were open where everybody was acting
with two meters apart i might consider
it
why are you so worried about omicron
i think it's just a volume of cases the
value of cases means the health service
can be
can be really putting a severe pressure
possibly overwhelmed because of the
number of people who present to hospital
because
possibly because they've got serious
symptoms are perhaps because they're
worried so if people don't act in a way
that keeps them safe and makes them feel
safe
and gets them to act in a way that
overwhelms the health service we've got
a big problem
the health service is a finite resource
it's been working very hard and i think
there's a great fear that we might crush
all those volunteers and all those
front-line workers between the
aspirations of the government
and and
the uh the fears of people who need good
good advice and good help
okay we must leave it there it's good to
talk to you thank you
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
the morning will be mainly dry once rain
over northern scotland clears into
shetland but it'll be rather gray with
further drizzle possible northeastern
britain and the south of ireland have
the best chance of sunshine but early
fog will be slow to clear it'll be mild
especially in the north although the
south will be a bit cooler than today
the afternoon will bring little change
although patchy rain may return to the
hebrides later
air pollution levels look set to stay
low despite the generally settled
conditions
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
maurice johnson called for christmas to
go ahead as normal but hospitality
bosses say the industry is struggling
under a wave of cancellations there are
caused by extra support during what
should be the busiest time of the year
for the michigan star chef tom carriage
is with us now hi tom good to see you
thanks for joining us um what did you
make of the press conference the news
conference yesterday from the prime
minister and the chief scientific
officer
well i think pretty much like everybody
else confusing and mixed messages like
like a real real issue
you have uh professor chris witte um
uh recommending that you prioritize or
de-prioritize where you go and what you
do and then you have the government who
are still um talking about going out to
hospitality um i think the message from
chris witty will be coming across loud
and clear to most people and most people
will also want to make sure that you
know they don't want to be
self-isolating over christmas that you
know people want to be healthy and well
and so as an industry i think pretty
much everybody completely understands
why people are cancelling and not going
out however as a government but
it really does need to step up and help
an industry that has been put under an
immense and incredible amount of
pressure over the last couple of years
that now this could be the real thing
that tips it over the edge
and many many places will close their
doors on that
run up to christmas and then not reopen
in the new year
what impact is it having on your
business
well to be honest those bookings are
coming in fast and furious i mean i
posted a thing on social media a couple
of days ago where we had
654 cancellations this is just in one
site over the last six days um and
and that was a reflection of the
industry it's a bigger picture i mean
for me i posted it out there yeah you
know and there there will be a lot of
people say yes you could afford it you'd
get well yes and probably myself
personally i can um however the
businesses and the the industry sector
has a wider picture a much bigger
picture really is going to be struggling
with this many many places take 20 to 25
percent of their revenue and that run up
towards christmas and new year and that
that's 20 to 25 of their yearly revenue
so
without that happening with you know if
that's reduced to you know 40 or 50
percent of what it normally would be it
will be uh catastrophic for the industry
us personally and the those
cancellations are coming in thick and
fast and it's going to be incredibly
difficult to maneuver moving through
into the new year because the confidence
for the bookings in the new year are
also looking very very slow
so i'm guessing that you are um
concerned almost predicting that that
businesses will be going to the wall as
a result of this
yeah 100 i mean this is where the
government really does need to step up
you know
we need to the problem that we had
throughout the last 18 months or two
years is the mixed messaging is that
there is no direct conversation there is
no understanding of whether there is any
form of government support coming
through to our industry and many others
you know whether it's airline or travel
you know from my point of view i can
only speak from from somebody in
hospitality but it always seems that the
government are always reactive rather
than proactive it appears that there is
conversations uh happen things happen
and then they have to react to the
consequences afterwards and yet again
this is another uh example of mixed
messaging and confusion
and then you have to question as to why
you know you have a point where um
chris whittie is saying one thing the
government don't appear to be backing
that up and saying the same thing
um
and you have to question is that because
there isn't a support package there um
or if there is it is time that which is
soon at wherever he's gone to be able to
say something to us and let us know
what's going on or is the government you
know are they worried about those
hundred uh rebel mps that were voting
against restrictions as is if even more
restrictions are put in place is it you
know
you have to question his boris johnson
playing politics with the hospitality
industry and the future of it
uh what do you think
i mean i think it's probably a mixture
of both i'm not gonna you know where is
mission center where is the conversation
why aren't we being given support let us
know if there is support coming in you
know at least we can start making some
form of decisions if there is no support
you have to let us know if there is
plans to bring furlough schemes back is
there is plans to reduce the v80 back to
five percent weight if there are you
know those bounce back loans that many
businesses took last year to be able to
survive to get to this point those
repayments have to start being they're
already being repaid the v80 has
increased twelve and a half percent
though you know utility bills have gone
up wages have gone up um there's a huge
amount of costs that are falling into
hospitality businesses across the board
and without any support
and bookings going down there is no way
that many businesses will be moving
forward so you know
it is a question of why isn't rishi soon
act speaking to us why is that why
aren't we being told and you know i do
question is boris johnson playing
politics um with people's lives and and
it's not me personally here there's
there's three million people employed in
hospitality that affects and it's not
just that it's the ripple effect you
know if we're not ordering you know 50
of the food then that has effect on
supply chain and that's massive that
affects agriculture fishery farming you
know it has a huge huge knock-on effect
here
where are you on covered passports
um from my point of view
if it's something that the government
wants to bring in i i understand it if
it makes people feel more comfortable
going into restaurants and spaces i
understand it again it is a restriction
that comes into business which means
numbers will be down so again it is a
call for support
and at the same point it's not something
that i feel that the hospitality
industry it should be policing you know
well we are at a point now where you
know we've all been in this pandemic for
you know nearly two years
we have to start taking social
responsibility for ourselves you know
make sure you are
a double vaccinated and you had your
booster jab or at least got your name on
the list have it done and
take natural flow tests if you're
worried about going out i think there's
a lot of social um and personal
responsibility that has to fall on on
individuals not just you know it's not
the job of hospitality to check
everybody coming in and out of venues
talk to me about the work you're doing
with marcus rashford ahead of christmas
yes so we've been working with marcus
since last april on the full-time meals
campaign which has been incredible it's
about that trying to encourage and the
the increase in the uptake of the
healthy startup ages um which is you
qualify for if you're pregnant or if you
have a child of four and under um and
you qualify for free school meals um so
what it allows you to do
the the the healthy starbucks is valued
at four pounds 25 and you can purchase
um fruit vegetables pulses tinned items
and so we've been putting together
budget friendly recipes and that i've
been cooking and that's been released on
facebook and instagram every sunday and
then marcus or some of our friends have
a go at cooking them as well um and then
moving forward from that marcus put
forward a challenge for christmas um
could i put together a recipe for to
feed six people for under 10 pounds or
around about 10 pounds using healthy
style vegetables and yes we have we've
been able to come up with a turkey
dinner which is basically
a kind of like a turkey roll stuffed
with
stuff with sausage meat and roasted
vegetables and there's even enough left
over to do a potato and carrot kind of
hash brown with fried eggs for boxing
day
amazing amazing what are you doing for
christmas
well at the minute we've got we've got
family coming over and i should be doing
a roast turkey and we'll be hanging out
the same as everybody else watching a
bit of italian watch kids run around
with brightly colored toys and
lots of noise i expect
lovely hopefully you'll be tuning in to
watches on christmas morning
without doubt kane
my day my day doesn't start without sky
news
i'm pleased to hear it so we'll clip
that up for a promo thanks a lot tom
it's good to talk to you much
appreciated thank you bye-bye
see you now coming up we're going to be
discussing the challenges facing the nhs
in both treating and preventing the
spread of omicron the shadow health
secretary west streeting will be joining
us in just a few moments time to reflect
on what we've been hearing from the
health minister she says that she will
be partying uh but she did confirm that
the number of omicron cases in hospital
remains the same as it has been all week
the very latest coming up in just a
moment on skype
[Music]